Father in heaven we want to thank you
again for this preparation day we ask
Lord now again that your Holy Spirit
would guide our minds
give us understanding Lord in this most
important subject I Pray Again in Jesus
name amen
okay somebody asked a question during
the break
first of all couple clarifications uh I
may have the facts wrong on that issue
of the
the the bright light as to when that
took place you know where Willie said it
was the angel I know that um
foreign
I know that that reference had been made
to Gabriel coming in in strengthening
sister white and bringing things fresh
to mind in the preparation of the great
controversy whether that was the same
with the light where the people saw the
light I'm not sure that experience also
took place
it was uh Royce who was telling me but
he was at Elms Haven recently and and
and he they said that the situation
where somebody saw the light was at a
time where sister white was very sick
and thought she was going to die so the
timing of those I may have had incorrect
but the events themselves did take place
I mean as far as the uh what else did he
mention
I think that was it
um
somebody checked me on the my apocryphal
statements there you see so
I need to double check onto some things
there uh there was one other thing oh
somebody to ask in regard to the
writings like of the Pioneers we were
halfway through this statement on page
seven seven a number two
says so I'm going to pick up in the
middle there a few are still alive who
passed through the experience gained in
the establishment of this truth God has
graciously spared their lives to repeat
and repeat till the close of their lives
The Experience oh no we read the whole
statement
uh there to Bear the last sentence there
there to Bear their testimony as to what
constitutes Truth for this time somebody
asked me about books like for example
Daniel and the Revelation you know
people are turning away from that
they're saying damn in the Revelation
isn't that accurate anymore what did
sister White say about Daniel in the
Revelation
um there's a couple statements here this
one is found in
manuscript releases
hold on a minute
manuscript releases volume 1 page 62.
and 63. the truth for this time has been
brought out in many books let those who
have been dealing in cheap sentiments
and foolish tests cease this work and
study the book Daniel and the Revelation
then they then I'm sorry they will have
something to talk about that will help
the mind
as they receive the knowledge contained
in this book they will have in the
Treasure House of the Mind a store from
which they can continually draw as they
communicate to others the great
essential truths of God's word
the interest in Daniel in Revelation is
to continue as long as probationary time
shall last
and then she goes on to say young men
take up the work of canvassing for
Daniel in Revelation do all you possibly
can to sell this book
enter upon the work with as much
earnestness as if it were a new book you
know sometimes the new book comes out
we're going to sell the new book okay
now Ellen White strongly endorsed the
book the end of the Revelation but don't
get the idea that that meant everything
in the book was without error okay
um the situation came in 1888 one of the
big controversies
in 18 at the 1888 General Conference was
that A.T Jones was teaching on Prophecy
and he taught that one of the ten horns
was the alamani which became the Germans
um Smith taught in Daniel in Revelation
it was in print it was the Huns and so
the older Saints got in a tiff about
this thing and were given all kinds of
grief to uh to A.T Jones for teaching
this and there was this this uh debate
going on about
um
this issue of the Huns versus the
alimony what ended up that Jones was
right
and I believe the newer versions of uh
Dan and Revelation have been edited and
that they contained that alimony instead
of the Huns there but the point is when
Ellen White gave her endorsement she
wasn't endorsing every piece in Daniel
in Revelation but she wasn't endorsing
Smith's methodology of interpreting
prophecy
okay you follow that
and much of what is said in the book
one other thing somebody had asked and
we talked about this just a little bit
before about the trumpets of Revelation
something to keep in mind the sixth
trumpet as we have it in print in the
great controversy element comments that
when Josiah litch predicted that the
Ottoman Empire would fall based on the
prophecy of the sixth trumpet on August
11 1840.
it did fall on August 11 1840. there are
people today who look back and they say
well I don't think it was a complete
fall I mean it was just this that and
then we start to discredit that okay but
here's where experience comes to play
see people who didn't live through the
experience can say that they don't
remember they don't realize that
when the Advent movement was going
forward and there were people who were
questioning the validity of this whole
thing many of them non-believers in
Christ period
they said if this prophecy thing is true
I want to see something come to pass now
this isn't why Josiah litch came up with
his interpretation but Josiah was so
convinced from his interpretation of
Prophecy that the Ottoman Empire would
fall on August 11 1840 he gave it to the
day
before it happened
he said on August 11 1840 this Empire is
going to fall and on August 11 1840 it
did and the unbelievers that you can
imagine the push that gave in 1840 to
the movement
I mean the truth just went forth like
wildfire because people said
non-believers said now we can believe
the Bible okay
and so those who didn't pass through
that experience don't know that we read
it and say well I don't I don't see that
understand that God uses things for
effect sometimes example
how many of you have heard the vision
element had in regard to the planets
okay early in her experience Joseph
Bates one of the founders of this
movement Joseph Bates the one who
discovered the Sabbath truth from the
perspective of Adventists he got it from
Rachel Oaks but you know the story but
uh Bates did not believe in the gift of
Prophecy there was so much crazy
business going on he said I don't
believe in it
Bates had been a sailor and one thing
sailors did very much is studied the
stars because that's how they navigated
okay and he loved astronomy Ellen White
had a vision in which she saw planets
and she described the planets and she
described the moons around the planets
and she described them in more detail
than Bates had ever heard anybody
described
Bates was there for that vision and when
she had finished up he says now I know
this is the true gift
now critics today will take that and say
here's what happened in Illinois's
Vision now here's what Bates did when
she described it he said well that's
Saturn you know that's Jupiter and he
would start naming them Ellen White
Never named the planet she saw in her
vision
never did but the point is afterwards
critics will say well we know today that
Saturn doesn't have five moons it has
six moons or it doesn't have them this
one ring it has two rings and we get
into all these so the critics get in all
these debates
question what was the purpose of the
vision
to tell people how many moons a planet
had or to convince one of the leaders in
the movement the gift was real
what Ellen White saw envisioned and what
Bates said oh that's he agreed with
everything known in that day
God meets people where they are for a
purpose understand the purpose that he's
giving something for you and I look back
and say I don't know August 11 18 40.
don't forget what the purpose was God
gave that for and don't forget you know
well forget a lot of you don't know
why that you know what what weight that
had on the Advent movement
by the way it's in great controversy so
I can recommend that book to you
um
number uh eight
not everything can be understood upon
the first and maybe many subsequent
readings
true Christians practice the principle
of suspend judgment suspend judgment is
like this and you've probably had
somebody word at something like this
before sometimes you come across
something you read it you study it you
can't make sense of it
you have to come to a point if you
believe in the Lord and you don't lose
your faith to take that thing you don't
understand and box it up and put it on a
shelf in your brain and say Lord one of
these days you're going to take that
thing down and open it up for me and
help me to make sense of it okay if you
and I could understand everything we'd
be God
the fact that we don't helps us to
understand that we're not God and he is
okay
and so you're dealing with the mind of
the infinite even the things in
scripture which God's given to us in
human language there are things that
take time they take experience I like
what Ray Holmes said he said he made
this point
he said every time and you'll notice
this in your experience how many of you
have noticed every time you come and
read something in the Bible you get
something new out of it now Ray Holmes
says this and I like this he says the
reason you get something new out of it
is because you're a different person
every time you read
because the Bible changes us
and the next time you come to that
passage you're a different person than
you were before God has expanded your
understanding God has taught you a
little Jesus told the disciples there
are many things I wish I could tell you
but you guys aren't ready for him yet
but they were ready for him later
weren't they takes time
so it may be many subsequent readings of
something that gives you an
understanding of it uh the example there
early writing is 38 this is my example
in early writings 38 you may have read
this vision of Ellen White where she
sees
the angels of God holding the Four Winds
and they're about to let them go
and then Jesus goes before his father
and he says father my blood my blood my
blood father
and when I first read that passage I
struggled with that so much the picture
I got was God was gunning for the Saints
and Jesus said no Dad don't do it
and I got this picture that there's the
Angry God the father and if it weren't
for Jesus we'd be obliterated
and if you read through that Vision it
reads that way and I thought I can't
understand this and it wasn't until
reading it again and again that I
started to understand and picked up
things I hadn't picked up before that in
the vision Ellen White says that God had
given those angels charge
over the Four Winds
and so they were about to release them
the father had given them that charge
Jesus didn't override Jesus went through
the chain of command and he went to his
father he says father I see people down
there that they don't see those angels
you know those Four Winds are the Four
Winds of human passion the Revelation
talks about it and alamite talks about
great controversy chapter uh time of
trouble
and the Four Winds are not let let loose
until the Servants of God are sealed in
their foreheads
you have these angels that were given
charge only those angels think everybody
okay I think everybody's decided
that Jesus saw people who hadn't decided
yet and he said father there's people
who haven't decided yet
now Jesus wasn't saying father don't
kill them yet
just saying father this we need to
change the command and then she says I
saw a bright light go from the father to
the Sun and from the Sun a message he
sent a messenger out to those angels and
said hold hold hold
right until the Servants of God are
sealed in their foreheads
so it you follow me there
uh well the first time I read that I got
a total different picture
and it took me probably a year or two
before I really started to grasp what
that was talking about I just had to box
it up put it in on the Shelf somewhere
I've still got some boxes on the Shelf
do you follow that
you know there's we can't understand
everything on the first reading be
diligent you know sometimes God
you know don't our parents tell us well
you're going to appreciate it more if
you got to work for it
right
it's true and sometimes the Lord wants
us to dig for things because when we get
the answer oh it means so much more
right
so not everything can be understood upon
first and maybe even many subsequent
readings okay let's go to the next
section councils against extremism
extreme according to the dictionary
is the greatest or utmost degree or
point
either of the two things situated at
opposite ends of a range now we may say
and I'm going to use the terminology
here
that I typically disdain
and that is
conservative
and
liberal
okay and this isn't just an adventism or
just in Christianity and these now if
somebody if I were to tell somebody I
would probably say that I'm a
conservative
yet at the other you know sometimes I
just fear what they think I mean
most people if they were to call me
something would call me conservative and
still I started talking about the
bicycles and then they might call me a
liberal okay we're gonna talk about this
in a minute too
but
I like there was an article that
appeared in one of the uh does anybody
has any anybody here seeing the
Adventist affirm little magazine
um there's an article that appeared a
little while ago by a man by the name of
Leroy Holmes I don't know who knows
neighborhood homes
I believe it's also in Samuel Pippen's
new book here we stand I think it was
reprinted on conservatives and liberals
and he makes this point I thought it was
fantastic
he said we we really hurt ourselves with
with these terms with this terminology
because typically a conservative is
somebody who takes the Bible as the
inspired word of God
I mean I'm not I'm not making that up a
liberal is somebody who they don't take
it so literally
they feel like you're being
narrow-minded to take everything in the
Bible so literally listen face it we're
in the Year 2005 man you know that's the
mindset of the liberal and so they take
liberties with with the scripture with
the spirit of Prophecy
uh it's not at all uncommon and and
actually probably pretty common for a
liberal to say I really don't believe
the Earth was created in six literal
days you know come on God's given us a
brain you got to think that's what
they'll say but the conservative says
you know regardless the Bible is I
believe it's the inspired word of God
and I believe that God meant what he
said when he wrote it okay
typically
here's what happens
now you have people who are you have
conservative Seventh-Day Adventists and
you have liberal seventh Adventists a
liberal seven a conservative Seventh-day
Adventist typically will believe in the
inspiration of the Bible the inspiration
of the spirit of Prophecy they believe
that the Sabbath should be observed from
Sundown Friday to sundown Sabbath they
don't think that the Sabbath should be
spent going out to eat and all this
other funny business you know and and
they they're they're you know doing
their best to follow what they
understand the Bible to teach now
liberal on the other hand a liberal may
say may even go so far as to say you
know what the Sabbath is not I I don't
believe that God's going to require that
for everybody who's going to be saved I
think it's a blessing and I think people
would appreciate the blessing but I
don't think it's mandatory now I've
heard this pastor Renner preached in a
pastor's Church who preached this in
Ohio when he was with ASI so then you've
got you know the Sabbath is a blessing
you did a whole series on Camp Meeting
about it
um
a a liberal seven-day Adventist might
say take that position I just shared on
creation we have liberal seven the
Adventists who say oh we we don't we
don't teach
um a literal Six-Day creation now here's
here's the point that Leroy Holmes made
this person is not an Adventist at all
no not a Christian at all
a Christian believes in the inspired
word of God and so the term liberal now
has allowed
a category of Christian that doesn't
even exist
okay
now so the terms can be used and
sometimes they're used rightly but a lot
of times this has just given us a
loophole to have people really don't
believe in the Adventist message
do you follow that
so I I refrain from using these words
conservative and liberal
you know I prefer to say you know you're
either a Bible believing Seventh-day
Adventist or you're not
okay you kind of follow that
but these would be extremes now there
are there are conservatives that you
would say you know and and sometimes
people will say Ultra conservatives
that's another term that people will use
who these are the people that preach
against bicycles and and to teach the
young girls that they should be
harnessing their horses and they just
take everything to an extreme Point okay
notice here this statement under B well
notice letter B the ice of indifference
or the fire fanaticism this is a
powerful statement testimonies Volume 5
page 644.
we have found in our experience that if
Satan can keep cannot keep Souls Bound
in the ice of indifference he will try
to push them what
Into the Fire of fanaticism this is two
ditches have you read have you seen
David Sherwood's little article on
ditches
you haven't seen that it's pretty it's
pretty sweet I saw it yesterday and I
said man I need to hand that out that
goes with he says I think everybody has
it so if you don't I'll copy it for you
but this is what we're talking about we
got two ditches here you've got to know
a straight and narrow road and the
straighter and narrower the road is
the easier it is to go into a ditch
okay
and that's what we're talking the devil
he didn't care which ditch you're in
he's going to put you in the ice of
indifference he can't keep you
indifferent yeah you know it doesn't
matter how I worship you know and
indifferent in other words your lacks in
your Christian experience if he can't
keep you there if you're on fire for the
Lord and he's going to try to push you
over the edge and get you make you
extreme on something okay so you're
preaching sermons about how the evils of
bicycle riding
do you understand that okay that's what
she's saying there letter c
that should have been letter b
I need an editor letter C take the
middle path
Ellen White's counsel here so council's
on diets and Foods notice where it's
found page 211 and 212. you need not go
into the water or Into the Fire
but take the middle of the the middle
path avoiding all extremes okay
and the next statement from testimonies
one page 425 there is a medium position
in these things oh that we might all
wisely find that position and keep it
and we're I'm gonna I'm gonna expound on
this as we go I'm just read through some
more of these things here uh letter D
don't over strain small points these are
the things that lead to a fanatical view
of things
councils on Health page 155 narrow ideas
and over straining of small points have
been a great injury to the cause of
hygiene
there may be such an effort at economy
in the preparation of food that instead
of a healthful diet it becomes a what
a poverty-stricken diet in one place she
says be careful that your health reform
doesn't become Health deformed
and I have a whole presentation that I
do on health deform it's called hell our
health message reform or deform
um one thing Ellen White says that I
don't have here she says if you're going
to air anywhere
err on the side of the people
what are we what are we trying to do
first and foremost we're trying to win
souls to the kingdom right
if you're in danger of offending a soul
over something that is not Eternal truth
don't do it if you've got a question err
on the side of the people that's that's
you know I'll get you that statement
somebody remind me to get that statement
during the break I like what rajakun
says there letter e every Vice is a
virtue carried to an extreme position
it's interesting when you think about it
um even you take drug abuse
how do you use that
um
I'm trying to take an extreme you know
drug abuse uh you know what would be the
what would be the The Virtue there no
I've met it could be a virtue you could
say in medication or just in health but
uh
maybe it's a vert maybe maybe we could
use it this way in Recreation because
why do people start taking drugs
for a good time don't have a good time
well there God wants us to have a good
time
but not like that and so it's taken to
an extreme we're looking for fun we're
looking for fulfillment we're looking
for excitement God doesn't ban that
but it's taken to an extreme
homosexuality
God created human beings with a sexual
drive
but it's taken two extremes
every virtue every Vice is a virtue
taken to extremes I think that's
interesting and Ellen White says
something similar in testimonies one
page 425 there is a medium position in
these things not wrong one below that
Evan's home uh 122. it is carrying that
which is lawful to excess that makes it
a grievous sin
that next letter F balance balance is
not a what
a teeter-totter listen I have people
today balances everybody's favorite word
today
be balanced got to be balanced and I've
heard people I've heard some of the most
horrendous sermons where a person's
trying to be balanced and this is what
they're doing
they go over here and they'll give you
one of these and then they'll come over
here and then they'll give you some ushi
gushy liberal nonsense and they'll say
that's balance you give them hard over
here and right in the midst of the
sermon but we don't want to do this but
you got to be straight over here but you
know now you want to be loving and
they'll go and they'll hit this back and
forth and you feel like you're just
going up and down like this that's not
balance
you don't have to do that with truth
because truth itself is balanced
truth is the Middle Road that's like
driving the car down the road like this
right that's not balance
stay on the middle of the road
okay
Douglas says here in uh in in the book
on page 401
truth as principle is not some kind of
balance between two errors
truth transcends errors of both extremes
by recognizing the truths that each
extreme wants to guard you know liberals
hold to some good points
believe it or not
a lot
but there are some good points that they
hold to liberals will tell you you got
to be loving you to care about people
well they're listen let me tell you
something I had a friend of mine went to
a camp meeting
and
I think we went to the Kentucky camp
meeting or something I I don't know who
the speaker was he comes back and I said
so brother how'd it go
oh it was all right but anyway it was
all right what oh that all they talked
about was love love love
and I said brother
yeah be careful
is there something wrong with talking
about now you know what he was talking
about they weren't talking really about
Divine love at all you know some kind of
really it was an extreme probably an
extreme View
but be careful how you talk like that
imagine imagine your your Bible study's
interest is there with you what's the
problem with that sermon they were just
talking about the love of God the whole
time and I couldn't stand it made me
sick
okay
are you do you follow what I'm saying
here now I knew what my friend was
saying but I told him I said brother you
know is there well he says you know what
I mean I said yeah but I said just when
you're when you're phrasing those things
uh recognize there's nothing wrong with
that
but
um recognize the truths that you know
don't say well he's a liberal so I'm not
going to listen to anything he says
just like I said the other day you can
get truth in any place when truth comes
to you you don't need to ask who brought
it to me you need to ask yourself is it
true amen
number two
be certain your balance is not simply
what
spiritual laziness
you know my brother shared this once and
I thought about it he says you know he
says in my Christian experience
I try to be balanced in my viewpoints on
things but he says you know sometimes
the Lord convicts me
you're not being balanced you're just
being lazy a lot of times we call it
balance so I'm going to be balanced in
my diet
and a lot of times the Lord's convicted
us of something and our balance isn't
balanced it's just that we don't want to
go where the Lord's leading us to go so
we kind of spiritually lazy we're not
living in a generation that we can
afford to be spiritually lazy amen
and we'll talk about that in just a
moment
I'm going to flesh out a few things for
you uh the quote there from review and
Herald January 9 1894 when we reached
the standard that the Lord would have us
reach
worldlings were regard Seventh-Day
Adventists as odd singular straight
laced what
extremists
we are not to seek to be extreme
but that does not mean we're not going
to be called Extreme okay
some people's balance is based on how
people view us and if somebody says
you're extreme man oh well I better be
balanced
you know what your balance isn't based
on what people think extreme is
balance is based on what the Bible
teaches and a lot of people's balance
is totally imbalanced if compared to the
word of God and the spirit of Prophecy
you follow that
so our our criteria is always the word
of God balance means not saying not
keeping everybody happy let me tell you
this
a truly balanced Christian
is not going to be popular in either
camp
you follow that
Bible example there were two Extremes in
Jesus day there were the conservatives
called who
the Pharisees and they were the Liberals
called who the Sadducees did either of
them like Jesus No in fact they
conspired together these mortal enemies
got together so they could get rid of
Jesus
if you're truly balanced you're not
going to be popular with anybody a lot
of our balance is so that we can fit in
and be popular somewhere
it's not the reason to be balanced
balance is based on truth and if you're
truly balanced you're going to be
considered an extremist by somebody
but don't be extreme don't give them a
reason to call you an extremist
other than following God's word and
being faithful to it do you follow that
any questions on that
let's move on
the effect I'm just going to touch this
briefly you can look this uh look some
of these references up the book brings
these up and when it's talking uh about
extremes the effect of people who
Advocate extreme views this is the
effect it has on the church they bring
truth into disrepute
a few people can discredit the entire
church
I'm not going to go into all the details
and just in my experience in Ministry
with what what what's happened in
churches when people take extreme views
but it's not good
I mean um
I'll give you an example
we had a woman in my church in Grand
Rapids who was learning now this woman
grew up in Christian Reformed home
uh and and to me from my best
observations a good Christian home
she married a Seventh-Day Adventist man
came into a set of meetings and was
baptized at those meetings became a
Seventh-Day Adventist
she decides she wants to change her diet
now she was a meat eater
okay her Adventist husband is who was
born and raised as a meat eater now
she's convicted that she wants to get
health conscious
she comes to a cooking school that we
have
and all of our cooking schools that we
do in accordance with Spirit of Prophecy
Council are vegan
did you know that
Illinois says teach the people how to
cook without milk and eggs that's what
we've got to do when I tell people the
cooking school is you all know how to
cook with milk and eggs
anybody ever try to cook without them
oh man that's not easy to do so we say
this is how you can cook without them
now it's your choice and I tell people
coming you've got Outsiders coming in
you if you're gonna you know you some of
you won't become vegetarians but here's
some health principles you can put into
practice maybe you can start to
incorporate some of these things into
your diet but we give them the optimum
and let them apply it you follow that
and this woman came and she was excited
and she wanted to put these things into
practice
we have Mary burnt doing a cooking
school for us in our church this next
week and if you've never heard one of
her cookie I told you about the
herbivore carnivore
awesome man she
anyway you know don't don't listen don't
listen to Mary burn on health until
you're ready to make some changes I'll
tell you that because it's just powerful
stuff but she this woman so she wants to
make some changes she comes to church
potluck
she makes this dish and
um
I think it was she brought some salad
dressing she brought a salad and salad
dressing she cooked her the food without
milk and eggs she was excited she felt
good and one of the members said she got
the salad dressing out and one of the
members goes to uh to get this and they
say uh don't touch that it has vinegar
in it
oh
now the woman and here's in her hearing
now here she thinks she's making
progress but she's got vinegar in the
dressing
I'm going to tell you something now
vinegar is not good for us okay element
has Counsel on it let me tell you
something look it up
my wife and I were talking about it once
and I said I'm curious I'm going to look
this up I think there are two original
references in all of her writings having
to do with vinegar with the exception of
the vinegar that Christ was offered on
the cross in regard to health there's
really not a lot written on it
it's certainly not enough to make
somebody stumble over like that they're
making progress and so you see now my
wife and I don't use vinegar
you know I always have to say this
because you know and then it's like oh
the Master's over here I'm a total vegan
vegetarian
but people will say wow isn't that he
said vinegar run this in you know
um are you following what I'm saying
here I think our health should be
optimal but you have to it's Progressive
and uh you imagine the effect that this
has on people as they're coming into the
church I mean they just they're just
trying to figure out how not to cook
Hamburger anymore and they're not
allowed to use vinegar it's it
the the council we have through Spirit
of Prophecy is that we need it needs to
be Progressive uh letter b they greatly
injure and hinder the cause of Truth
some references you can look up in
Illinois's writings they make Christian
duties burdensome
they raise a false standard and then try
to force everyone else up to it
have you encountered this thing about
kneeling for prayer
some of you have Ellen White makes a
statement to this one Minister she was
in the service and the minister got up
to he was standing up to pray and she
says brother get down on your knees
before the almighty God this should
always be the position in prayer
and so some people have taken that
statement say well you know I pray all
the prayer for every prayer you pray at
your dinner time for your meals you pray
for the invocation you kneel kneel kneel
for every prayer because that's what the
prophet says but they didn't read all
that the prophet has spoken neither did
they read the scripture that says when
Nehemiah went in before the king and the
King said Nehemiah why are you troubled
Nehemiah knew he just might lose his
life because you're not allowed to go
with in before the king with a with a
discouragement on your face
the Bible says Nehemiah breathed up a
prayer and I'll guarantee you need it
but I didn't say
and get up okay
you following that
Ellen White has other counsel Ellen
White herself stood for some prayers she
was talking about the Pastoral prayer in
this in the in the service
but I have had people and you can
imagine you can only imagine that I've
read that Neil in every prayer
and so the pastor stands up for the
invocation he bows his head asked the
congregation and you have a couple of
Neil well then a couple people around
them what do we do you know and and this
has happened this has happened in
churches it happened when we were in
Mission College and Pastor Troy's
addressed it with the class because
people come in and then next thing you
got half the class
you know and and nobody knows what
they're doing half the class is kneeling
nobody well you know
read all that the prophet has spoken
it's it's confusing
they raise a false standard that God
didn't give us and then fourth try to
force everyone else up to it okay
Satan uses them to cast contempt upon
the work of the Holy Spirit well people
are going to say man if this is what
this Spirit of Prophecy is about I don't
want nothing to do with it
right
that's so that's what she's talking
about or that's what this statement
rather is talking about the work of the
Holy Spirit they
oh I it should say there they
spiritualize they spiritual eyesight is
perverted their spiritual eyesight is
perverted
okay so these are some effects on the
extreme views
now let's touch on these last I'm going
to just briefly touch on these last
areas we've touched on a couple of them
um Health reform I talked a little bit
about that uh in general you know I
wanted to say health reform in general I
mean the exercise and the whole thing of
it uh obviously diet is a portion of
that dress
my wife and I have been looking at this
lately and I'm not the the the jury's
still out on this one for me
I have
um
some people that are totally fixed and
you've probably been dealt with this
that women should never wear pants
or only in very rare occasions should
wear pants okay oh and and the reason I
Think We Gather that primarily because
there was what was called the American
costume
you'll look this up in elements writings
American costume and um
Clifford Goldstein comments on it here
let me let me see if I can
you have this book
yeah it's a good book good book
um he he touches on some of the Critics
on Ellen White in the back and this is
one of the things that they'll bring up
Ellen White had a vision on dress on on
dress length at one point in time
you know the women in her day wore
dresses so long that they would drag the
streets and they didn't even have the
nice clean swept streets and sidewalks
that we have you know they were
horse and buggy
this is pretty dirty streets okay and
they would gather the filth on the and
so she said the Lord showed me in Vision
that the length of the dress should be
shorter and then she says basically
about nine inches from the ground
and one of the Saints said wow sister
white says nine inches and it's nine
inches it used to be nine inches and
Ellen White had to clarify clarify this
in her writings and basically say look
the Lord didn't show me nine inches
the Lord just showed me and I from what
I saw I estimated nine inches she says
when I put when I quote what the Lord
shows me in the words of the Angel she
says I'll put them in quotation marks
and that got her in trouble later on
because then they'd say well you know
they they get on about what was it you
know it was in the context that she said
that she was going to take those words
and she said the words that I speak are
my own unless I put them in quotation
marks
referencing that they're the words of
the Angel well then when you get into
the plagiarism charges they say well
those words weren't exactly your own and
you didn't put them in quotation marks
it wasn't even the same situation she
was talking about whether my words are
the words of the Angel okay so that the
words of the Angel we know that is
verbal dictation
that's what she was saying when it's in
quotation marks that's what the angel
told me
and the angel didn't tell her nine
inches he just gave her an idea of the
length of dress
anyway there was a lot of uh
obviously a lot of uh
turmoil that came in over that
and let me just see I had it in this
book and I just want to share some with
you
on the issue of duress
there's part of it she says uh
now this is where my partner would come
in and say well he's looking that up
okay now listen to this
uh Clifford Goldstein and now Clifford
Goldstein is sharing in this book that
he used to lean towards a verbal
inspiration
he's like well she said nine inches and
so he says here now to me it was
perfectly clear the creator of the
universe had shown his prophet in vision
three companies of females passed before
me she said and she saw the length of
dress
the the creator of the universe had
shown his profit and vision what the
correct length of women's dresses should
be how could there ever been any
question again in any faithful Adventist
mind Yahweh had spoken and what does the
Lord speak other than absolute
irrefutable and terminal truth
however at some point later still in my
Adventist nasancy says I read the
following from Ellen White
the question may be asked why has this
dress been laid aside
and for what reasons has dress reform
ceased to be advocated the reason for
this change I will briefly I will hear
briefly State while many of our sisters
accepted this reform from principle
others opposed the simple healthful
style of dress which it advocated it
required much labor to introduce this
reform among our people it was not
enough to present before our sisters the
advantages of such address and to
convince them that it would meet the
approval of God
fashion had so strong a hold upon them
that they were slow to break away from
its control even to obey the dictates of
reason and conscience
and many who profess to accept the
reform made no change in their wrong
habits address except in shortening the
skirts and clothing the limbs nor was
this all
some who adopted the reform were not
content to show by example
the advantages of the dress giving when
asked their reasons for adopting it
and letting the matter rest there they
sought to control others conscience by
their own if they wore it others must
put it on they forgot that none were to
be compelled to wear the reform dress
you're picking up kind of the principle
there she said it was not my duty to
urge the subject upon my sisters
after presenting it before them as it
had been shown me I left it to their own
conscience much unhappy feeling was
created by those who were constantly
urging the reform dress upon their
sisters with extremists this reform
seemed to constitute the sum and
substance of their religion
it was the theme of conversation and the
burden of hearts and their minds were
thus diverted from God in the truth
they were so absorbed with dress
they weren't even they'd gotten away
from the truth their minds were so
absorbed she says
I mean incredible some were greatly
troubled because I did not make the
dress a test question and still others
because I advise those who had
unbelieving husbands and children I'm
sorry
still others were upset let me start
that again
some were greatly troubled because I did
not make the dress this reform dress a
test question and still others because I
advised those who had unbelieving
husbands or children not to adopt the
reformed dress as it might lead to
unhappiness that would counteract all
the good to be derived from its use
she actually counsels some people not to
use it
for years I carried this burden the
burden of this work into and labor to
establish uniformity of dress among our
sisters I had no burden on testimony of
testimony on the subject of dress she
goes on to say and um
the point there if I were to sum it up
she said there's two reasons that she
stopped advocating the reformed dress
number one
and don't miss number one that God's
people were so worldly minded that
recommending the benefits of following
God's truth wasn't important to him
wasn't as important to them as following
the Fashions of the world
and so she quit beating a dead horse
basically the other was a few of the few
that did adopt it wanted to hammer it on
everybody and then make it and try to
make themselves the criteria for
everybody else and then they got hop and
mad when everybody else didn't do just
what they thought they should do and
they took issue with Ellen White then
because Ellen White kind of backed off
her on her position and uh they got mad
because she had said to some people hey
if you've got an unbelieving husband
this probably isn't the best way to
introduce him to the truth
you follow
now I'm going to elaborate a little bit
more on this
the dress of society today is deplorable
especially for ladies I have a young
daughter and my wife's like I gotta
learn how to sew
because you try to find and I've got I
mean an elder friend of mine in the
church in Grand Rapids is uh is um
he's got older girls and when they try
to shop for clothes for them it's like
where in the world do we find anything
now let me just tell you something and
uh I'm going to be kind of blunt here
when Jesus said if a man looks at a
woman to lust after in his heart he's
committed adultery
why didn't he say when a woman looks
after a man to lust after
him
well it was a patriarchal dinner right
no it's not
I'm going to tell you folks and you may
disagree
science will bear this out very clearly
that if man has any great downfall we
saw it in the beginning is lusting after
women
more so than women lust after men men
are visually stimulated women are not
visually stimulated in the same sense
that men are
and you know what if you ladies don't
know that the fashion designers do know
that and that's why they make clothes
the way they do and that's why women are
dressed the way that they are and so the
principles of dress not the policy
the principles of dress are those of
modesty that was one principle an
important one another one was Ellen
White commented that the women didn't
have their limbs properly clothed in
other words
um you go out in cold weather with a
sleeveless shirt it's not good for your
circulation it's not good for your body
it leads to different kinds of sickness
Etc
so just Health uh women were wearing
clothes like uh these these hoops that
would hold their skirts in the big
circles okay would pull down would weigh
down on their hips and on their
very unhealthy they would wear the um
corsets where it would suck their
stomach in and all their internal organs
and so there were lots of big problems
health-wise modesty-wise Etc with rest
here's another reason
I'm just wondering I should probably
give you a a break
um
well the ladies come back after the
break if we're talking about them this
goes for guys we're going to talk about
the guys too but I I think you know guys
Fashions stay pretty pretty similar
girls Fashions change more than guys
guys aren't usually as fashion conscious
in fact
our wives usually have to help us dress
you know so
let's take a break and we're going to
come back and we'll pick up here